this is from wng.org Washington Jerry
convicts five pro-lifers I find this
story absolutely fascinating they say
the jury on Tuesday found the five
activists guilty of violating the
freedom of access to Clinic entrances
act authorities immediately took the
pro-livers into custody they now await
their sentencing and their lawyers are
planning an appeal the trial which began
with the jury selection on August 9th
centered on the participation in a 2020
sit-in at a facility in DC where they
suspected an abortionist of Performing
illegal late-term abortions each of the
activists face the possibility of a
possibility of up to 11 years in prison
three years of supervised release and as
much as 350 000 in fines
we've uh we've talked about the
escalating conflict culture War called
cold culture we're going to call it and
one of the examples that we often give
is Colorado and I think Oklahoma right
yeah they border each other in one state
abortion is completely illegal and in
another state it is completely
unrestricted
which opens the door to some very
serious
troubles if say some a woman flees the
state where it's overtly illegal in
every respect into Colorado for the
abortion which is likely happening now
as we speak and then there is a
challenge from another individual says
no stopper she can't do it's illegal
what happens does Oklahoma send police
to stop the one from aborting and
killing the baby because they view it as
murder or do they not view it as murder
what I find interesting with the story
about these activists is that if you
take the perspective that abortion is
murder and that this doctor may have
been performing late-term abortions you
have a story of Five individuals who
took no direct physical action to stop
an active murder from taking place
simply sat in front of a building where
a murder was taking place and will now
be going to prison for trying to stop
that murder again that's if you take
that perspective
that I gotta say it's very interesting
to me because it says to me I don't I
don't actually think uh conservatives
think it's it's murder and it was
actually there I I can't remember who
was making the argument it was actually
a pro-life Christian conservative who
said clearly there is something
different about it in that even pro-life
activists do not behave similarly
overwhelmingly there may be some
individuals who would view it completely
as the same same thing but for the most
part the political conservatives that
say it is murder
do not act like it is
so I'm wondering if you know for one
this is a crazy story and I'm mentioning
what you guys think and showing what you
guys think about it I'm also interested
in and where we go from here considering
this I honestly think that I I think
that the whole I don't want a dog pile
on people that are so pro-life that they
think a one day old inceptive child is
the same holistically as a 17 year old
boy
um so yeah murder destroying a
fertilized egg at one day and killing a
17 year old in Cold Blood are very very
different and I feel like it's LARPing
to act like it's a murder why is it
different because it has no cognizant
sentience as far as we know so a person
who's like in a coma you can kill
no it has nothing to do with it I'm
talking about a one day old inceptive AG
Sac or whatever it is and then an adult
human
um they're just different so I find like
this Obsession and you see it here like
I explain it to us I don't understand
what you're trying to say well it
doesn't know English it probably can't
do math I don't think it can even speak
it doesn't have okay I don't think it
has auditory abilities but I don't think
does a six month old have that ability
I'd have to pull out the thing and look
at it to examine to see what all it's
developed at that point at six months
but usually by 24 weeks I think you've
pretty much become a human
so you're taking the vosh approach in
that babies aren't actually alive until
some point after they're already born
it's living tissue
20.
so you're saying during pregnancy and
you're saying after birth just I'm sorry
you're saying after consent 24 weeks
after conception making sure we're not
talking about a two-year-old no uh six
six months six months four months I
don't know something like that well but
at some point it starts to become human
and it's still living I'd never say it's
not alive but whether or not it's a
murder depends on whether or not it's a
human being well the law the law yeah
correct so intentionally killing a human
life is not murder no it's not a human I
don't think it's a human until you know
six six weeks or whatever it's 24 hours
what is it
what's it called a zygote
um
describing a human though all those
terms to describe the stages of
pregnancy are all describing what
eventually be is a human who's gonna say
it becomes a human but
they're all ways to describe it from
Ian's perspective dogs are zygotes too
at some point is like an undeveloped
animal
so like here here's here's I I mean I
don't want to get into the argument over
abortion I'm more concerned with the
political ramifications of these people
being arrested and their perspective on
it but uh I accept your uh uh
perspective Ian I'm not sure I
understand what you're trying to say I
don't think you've actually you've
accurately articulated in a way that I
or many people could understand I when
people say that abortion is murder I
think it is kind of like a LARP I I I
like people were in that building
getting killed in Cold Blood those
people would not be arrested well this
is the point I actually made these
people believe that a murder they claim
a murderer taking place so they sit down
and hold hands yeah I I don't think they
actually believe that I I agree with you
uh I do think that uh babies are alive
uh in the womb and all that I do think
you know at one day of conception there
is a human life there that would be
killed in an abortion but there's
clearly something different about it in
that these activists and almost every
single activist their position is well
another murder happened today let's
let's write it down I'm like yeah when
you see a video of store clerk being
robbed and the guy starts mercilessly
beating into the stick these people are
cheering and celebrating yeah when it
comes to this they're like let's sit
down in front of the building now I'm
not stupid I understand there is a
political climate here and these people
are trying to do the non-violence Civil
Disobedience which is the appropriate
way to protest what our society deems in
many respects acceptable well half does
not they're taking the non-violent
approach to a
conflicted issue in this country which
is in my opinion
non-violence of disabases the correct
way to address these things but they're
going to prison for it if you can't sit
down in front of a building and Link
arms will they trespassing yeah I was
gonna say is this a state that has one
of the the barriers yeah so they're
saying that you they're they're within
the violation like what were yes they
were in DC and DC has a law saying you
can't block access to a clinic so are we
are are we getting to the point because
we saw jensaki I don't know if you saw
this the other day you know saying that
well you know the the the the whole
thing about you know Democrats being a
fan of late-term abortions is misleading
are they starting to back away from this
now because this how we even got to the
point where there are a lot of Democrats
there are a lot of people on the left
that are okay with all the way up to the
point of you know a week before birth
okay with terminating a pregnancy so are
we starting to back away from that I
think I think a lot of people equate uh
supporting something with happiness I
think there's a lot of people that I've
talked to that are pro-abortion they're
not happy about it they support it they
want it to be legal but they don't get
joy out of it I think that's the more
normally like normal approach when it
comes to being uh pro-choice
but
I think it's still there uh yeah I don't
I don't see anything backing away from
it I think because Roe v Wade's kind of
in the rear view mirror right now we've
talked about it less as a country but
it's going to come back right now in
this country Roe v Wade has been
overturned
some states have decided to outright ban
abortion some states have decided to
make it unrestricted Limitless the
Democrats of course lie endlessly like
like I've got to mention gen sackey says
nobody wants this but all of these
states you have I should say all of you
but many of these states are enacting
these laws
you may say you know oh people have
gotten arrested for you know
non-violence Civil Disobedience in front
of these clinics before but we're now at
a point where
the conflict may be coming 2828 to a to
Greater tension with like I mentioned
Colorado and Oklahoma bordering each
other and one saying absolutely not one
saying under under any circumstances
with stories like this
pro-lifers are being told there is no
non-violent Civil Disobedience path
towards resisting what they view as
murder my fear is what happens after
that because the last thing we want is
anything to escalate but the government
is going to put these people in prison
for sitting down in front of a building
how long uh up to 11 years I think it is
000 fine too so up to you know the
courts may say you know a year or
something they may get probation but
either way we've got these people
blocking highways they get arrested for
it you got these activists that do the
non-violent Civil Disobedience all the
time you had far left a storm one of the
Senate buildings storm the Capitol
Building previously for like Roe v Wade
stuff banging on the Supreme Court doors
no problem you got far leftists trying
to burn down the White House burning
down a guard post in front of the White
House setting fire to St John's Church
what did we get from that nothing
I'm like this is getting scary you know
that's all I can say there's got to be a
way with abortion to have this
conversation that is going to heal the
system because instead of being like
screaming no yes no that doesn't work
instead of being like murder murder
murder murder when it's not legally a
murder don't scream that it is because
it's not legally one hold on there are
some states where it is legally murdered
right now what happens if so in a state
where it's not a legal murder and so
it's no point in screaming murder that's
not the way well but also so we'll take
an eight-month-old baby in the womb stop
right there stop right there this is the
conflict I'm actually talking about if
you live in Oklahoma it is codified that
you are that it is illegal to perform an
abortion so the people in that state
have stated by their own Democratic
processes
you cannot kill this baby
if you live in that state and there are
many people who live in many states not
have enacted these restrictions or total
bans they are saying it's murder and
they have made it completely illegal
other states have said the inverse it is
not murder and it is unrestricted
so you can't just say it's not a murder
now because some states are saying it
effectively is that's an interesting way
to look at killing but you're right but
where does this conflict go then if you
have this is why I'm saying this is a
federal uh question this is a question
under the 14th Amendment I guess it
depends on your definition of a
naturally born citizen because if
they're not born then the 14th Amendment
may not actually protect them but the
14th Amendment actually says something
to the effect of Human Rights not being
denied this is work it's interesting
yeah because when you have an
eight-month-old baby and you look at it
in the eyes and it's looking at you you
know it's a human just but it's I've had
friends that were born premature but
they could have been aborted in certain
States illegally and I'm like but once
you know like that if you can know maybe
you would be less likely to want to do
it the issue right now that I bring up
is if Oklahoma says it's murder and it's
illegal and cholera says no it's not and
you can kill the baby
this this something is broken in this
country you cannot have a nation where
certain jurisdictions determine a
someone a that human DNA and matter is
not worthy of Life rights and one state
saying they are this is a recipe for
exactly what we saw back in 1861. some
states saying you do not have human
rights while other states you said you
do have human rights this is this is an
impossibility they cannot these two
positions cannot coexist so there are 30
states where it is considered double
homicide if you kill a pregnant woman 15
of those States abortion is is fully
legal up to so it is murder yeah so I
don't understand how do you have that
double standard that's what I don't know
I've never understood that no is it are
you saying it 100 sure it's considered a
murder or is it just an illegal killing
of some sort like a man homicide
homicide because murders of federal
crime homicide means human killing human
if you are correct in that if there's a
woman who's pregnant and you you know
you're drunk and you crash into them
they say you killed two people there's
two homicides it's a double homicide
they are saying a human killed a human
and that unborn baby was a human it
could be looked at as like um as a
manslaughter you know not necessarily A
murder murders of different murders like
a federal crime so I don't know it's
murder you're still I mean or even if
it's manslaughter I mean you're still
slaughtering a human that that's the
that's the whole point of manslaughter I
agree no no and I'm fairly certain in
the states you're referring to
if a deranged serial killer takes a
machete and goes to a pregnant woman and
butchers her killing both the baby and
the woman it is a double murder
she shoot the woman even if you just
shoot the woman I mean it's like because
it's yeah if the baby dies the baby is
going to die as a result yeah thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time